it is better to fail in originality than
to succeed in imitation roles before
9:00 a.m. action designer Gianni Versace
was shot on the steps of his bill
announced vers sashe singer ass Liberace
it was a create he was a genius
everything you see around us this house
this company was his life I will not
allow that man that nobody to kill my
brother twice what brings you to my ad
I know people oh yeah Versace Versace
Versace has invited me to the Opera
you're creative yes of course isn't that
special and you have experience with
older men
I'm very good with older men it's a gift
they've got a lot going I'm a fashion
Stu I'm building assets from the Titanic
I was married finances I was born in
East I'm also the godfather of her son
what do you do for work I worked for my
father on his pineapple plantations in
the Philippines you know I'm writing a
book about it I can't do it again you
can't what stop lying
Andrew Cunanan 27 years old he's killed
for me
he wasn't enough for you to slice this
house wouldn't walk what men value this
world has wasted me and yet this world
also made you mr. Prasad into a stock
you're not better than me are the same
the only difference is that you can't
luck the assassination of Gianni Versace
premieres Wednesday January 17th on FX
you